[Musique]
france 2022 l'heure du choix moins d'un
mois de l'élection présidentielle du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ici en france notre
rendez vous désormais quotidiens avec
vous assurer de verdure bonjour raphaël
et on va d'abord revenir sur la première
grande soirée électorale avec quasiment
tous les candidats y à la télévision
quasiment tous mais oui ils n'ont pas
débattu et du coup et bien pas mal de
critiques aujourd'hui dans les équipes
de campagne oui alors celui candidats
raphaël sur 12 étaient conviés ce qui a
évidemment était dénoncé par les quatre
qui ont été exclus on va y revenir un
format aussi inédit vous l'avez dit car
sans confrontation directe les candidats
se sont au final succédé sans se croiser
ni échangé directement la faute à
emmanuel macron qui avait imposé ses
conditions à la chaîne tf1 en refusant
tout débat à 8 récap de cette soirée
électorale avec florent auto et lucile
la tour
c'est l'histoire d'une émission
politique à l'image de cette campagne
inédite bienvenue à tous dans cette
grande émission la france face à la
guerre quatre candidats sur douze n'ont
pas été conviés pas de débat mais des
attaques contre emmanuel macron punching
ball de ses rivaux la réponse elle a été
trop tardive et puis trop solitaire
aussi je pense qu'il fallait aller à
moscou avec l'ensemble des représentants
européens pour montrer la puissance de
l'europe cette europe des sanctions
marine le pen en conteste le bien fondé
ce que je ne souhaite pas c'est que les
français se fasse hara kiri aux motifs
de sanctions décidées par nos dirigeants
pour anne hidalgo les grands groupes
énergétiques doivent mettre la main au
portefeuille sa solution un impôt de
guerre européens sur leurs bénéfices il
faut bien sûr aller chercher là où il y
aller une profil les moyens à situation
exceptionnelle mesure exceptionnelle
c'est le credo de fabien roussel
favorable lui aussi à une surtaxe des
géants pétroliers total il doit baisser
le prix de l'essence tout de suite et
moi s'il ne le fait pas je taxerait 100
% des dividendes parce que nous sommes
en période de guerre yannick jadot lui
va encore plus loin il veut couper les
vannes du gaz et du pétrole russes oui
il faut l'embargo de suite mais oui
parce qu'en fait chaque jour nous
donnons 700 millions de dollars à
poutine pour financer sa guerre rendre
le prix de la guerre insoutenable pour
vladimir poutine c'est la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron président-candidat
réticents à l'idée de traiter le maître
du kremlin du dictateur
idem pour jean luc mélenchon eric
zemmour c'est un autocrate c'est
absolument certain type je disais oui
c'est un dictateur abominable en fou
sanguinaire etc mais ça rend la gestion
de la france complètement impossible et
ça nous met en danger monsieur venancio
nous parle d'amour il va me mordre voilà
je ne vais pas insulter vladimir poutine
s'est évidemment quelqu'un qui a des
méthodes rude qui méthodes tyrannique
mais je ne vais pas le qualifier car
après il faut discuter avec lui voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
voilà les candidats exclus de cette
soirée électorale ont donc dénoncé je
vous le disais le format de l'émission
nicolas dupont aignan debout la france
nathalie arthaud candidate lutte
ouvrière jean lassalle du parti
résistons et philippe poutou du nouveau
parti anticapitaliste il a tweeté sa
colère la prochaine fois on peut
carrément annuler la campagne et le vote
ça ira plus vite un tweet assorti du
hashtag ou et futuna et puis jean
lassalle lui menace a d'ores et déjà de
se retirer de la course où il déplore
d'être traité je cite comme un candidat
de merde et il fustige une élection qui
n'a plus de sens en l'absence de
véritable confrontation on écoute
c'était aujourd'hui à l'issue du grand
oral des candidats devant l'association
des maires de france
je ne sais pas
si je serai candidat ce soir parce que
cette élection n'a plus aucun sens elle
n'avait ressemble le plus à rien c'est
l'élection suprême d'un des plus grands
pays du monde les regarde et des restes
de malheureux débat auquel je ne sonne
pas invité pas plus qu'hier soir ils
sont tous d'accord en tout cas sur un
point pour critiquer un le refus des
manuels macron de débattre avant le
premier tour ils se sont trouvé un allié
de poids les candidats le deuxième
personnage de l'état le président du
sénat oui dans une interview au figaro
gien larcher par ailleurs membre des
républicains tacle emmanuel macron ils
l'accusent de vouloir je cite enjamber
la présidentielle il ajoute que le chef
de l'état n'a sans doute pas envie de
confronter son bilan en réalité et il va
même jusqu'à questionner la légitimité
d'un président qui serait telus en
campagne cette interview a provoqué
beaucoup de réactions indignées sur
twitter sous le hashtag larcher à des
missions la guerre en ukraine un peu
occulté un anniversaire puisque c'est
cette semaine qu'un complément le 60e
anniversaire des accords d'evian qui
mirent officiellement un terme à la
guerre d'algérie acheter oui et 60 ans
après raphaël la mémoire de la guerre
d'algérie fait toujours l'objet de
débats en france emmanuel macron on l'a
vu à multiplier durant son quinquennat
les gestes forts vis-à-vis d'âge est ce
que certains candidats à la
présidentielle ont critiqué on en parle
ce soir avec vous meriem amellal bonsoir
merci nous avoir rejoints je le rappelle
vous êtes présentatrice du jt afrique
sur france 24
soixante ans après l'indépendance
comment est ce que les différents
candidats à la présidentielle en france
se positionne sur cette mémoire de la
guerre d'algérie alors raphaël l'a dit
ça a été un peu occultés l'algérie a été
peu présente par rapport aux autres
campagnes présidentielles dans là quand
dans la campagne a été peu abordée par
les candidats et surtout cette semaine
on verra c'est vendredi l'anniversaire
mais pour l'instant on n'en parle pas
beaucoup mais ça a été quand même évoqué
ici et là notamment par valérie pécresse
la candidate
lr qui avait évoqué au passage souvenez
vous lors de la polémique après le suite
au drapeau européen sous l'arc du
triomphe elle avait dit je cite je crois
qu emmanuel macron un problème avec
l'histoire de france il est allé dire en
algérie que nous avions commis des
crimes contre l'humanité donc voila vous
voyez ces déclarations qui sont qui sont
faites ici et là mais qui ne se
concentre pas sur la question mémorielle
et valérie pécresse fait référence à une
déclaration des manuels m'apprend
lorsqu'il était candidat en 2017 parce
qu emmanuel macron cette fois n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de l'algérie mais vous
l'avais dit il ya des gestes un des
gestes forts lors du quinquennat et tout
le monde s'accorde à dire les historiens
les observateurs qu'il en a fait plus en
un quinquennat que tous les présidents
de la vème république la reconnaissance
de l'assassinât de maurice audin celle
de ali boumendjel la restitution des
crânes mais aussi les événements du 17
octobre les manifestations du 17 octobre
donc on voit qu'il ya des gestes qui ont
été faits et d'ailleurs y compris
aujourd'hui une gerbe de fleurs a été
déposée devant le
l'endroit où a été assassiné l'écrivain
j'irai mouloud feraoun c'est le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron qui a demandé à
l'ambassadeur d'algérie de france en
algérie de déposer cette gerbe de fleurs
donc il ya des gestes qui sont faits
mais pas trop pas trop de prises de
position et peut-être que cela va
changer
ces jours ci avec justement
l'anniversaire des accords d'evian mais
pour l'instant je trouve que l'algérie
est très peu présente dans la campagne
comparé aux précédentes campagnes
présidentielles des douze candidats
jeudi 12 pour l'instant la seule est
toujours parmi nous il en est un qui a
un lien particulier avec l'algérie c'est
eric zemmour oui on peut dire qu'eric
zemmour déjà c'est le seul candidat qui
a un nom algériens parce que zemmour
c'est un patronyme qui est très fréquent
en algérie il ya des mêmes des villes
qui s'appelle zemmour zemmouri et
d'ailleurs il n'a jamais nié ses
origines algérien il dit qu'il est juif
berbère originaire d'algérie
c'est aussi le candidat qui a beaucoup
parlé de l'algérie mais plus quand ils
étaient éditorialistes que depuis qu'il
est candidat il avait fait part par
exemple de son admiration pour le
général bugeaud qui avait le maréchal
bugeaud qu'ils avaient qui avait conduit
les conquêtes coloniales et commis des
massacres en algérie lors de la
colonisation
eric zemmour c'est aussi celui qui
répond parfois qui se justifie avec ses
origines lorsque marine le pen le
critique en disant qu'il ya des néonazis
qui participa à ses meetings il répond
c'est pas possible je suis juive
d'algérie alors c'est un terme qui est
assez intéressant parce que je dirais
plus qu'il est qui les algériens de
confession israélite parce que sa
famille est originaire d'algérie et
berbères d'algérie elle a été elle est
devenue française par le décret crémieux
en 1870 elle a perdu sept nationalités
pendant l'époque vichyste elle l'a
retrouvé par la suite donc il a vraiment
ses origines
en algérie en revanche est ce qu'il
parle plus de l'algérie je dirais oui
mais la question algérienne chez eric
zemmour elle se décline dans plusieurs
thèmes l'immigration la délinquance
l'islamisme il ya une espèce de
glissements et d' amalgame qui se fait
comme chez d'autres partis d'extrême
droite donc oui elle est présente la
question algérienne il a dit plusieurs
fois d'ailleurs qu'il était contre la
repentance mais ils en parlent pas
forcément ouvertement sais c'est pas un
thème qui est abordée en tant que tel et
de manière générale meriem est ce que la
population algérienne s'intéresse à
cette campagne alors là aussi c'est
intéressant parce que ça a beaucoup
changé moi j'ai couvert le
cinquantenaire de l'indépendance en 2012
et j'avais remarqué déjà que les jeunes
s'intéresser - l'histoire de l'algérie à
l'époque et depuis le le
2019 et le mouvement de contestation y
est bien il ya eu un vrai changement la
jeunesse est approprié son histoire et
elle s'intéresse à la france
différemment et un détachement sait on
regarde cette campagne présidentielle
avec beaucoup moins de passion on
regarde cette campagne comme on
regarderait une campagne d une grande
puissance comme on s'intéresse aux
élections américaines ou d'autres pays
mais il ya un détachement parce que
c'est une nouvelle génération vais vous
proposer de regarder une image qui en
dit long c'est l'image d' emmanuel
macron à alger
en tant que président qui rencontre un
jeune de 24 ans alors cette image c'est
quoi ce jeune algérien lui dit monsieur
le président et la guerre d'algérie lui
répond mais qu'est ce tu mens brouille
tu as quel âge il lui répond j'ai 24 ans
et demi n'a pas vécu la guerre dit oui
mais ma grand mère l'a vécu alors ça
c'est très intéressant d'abord l'image
on a un président qui est jeune qui n'a
pas vécu la guerre d'algérie on a un
jeune algérien de 24 ans qui n'a pas
vécu la guerre d'algérie c'est ça qui
résume les nouvelles relations c'est une
nouvelle génération suite le discours
c'est un discours d'un président
français qui parle de l'histoire avec un
grand h est un jeune algérien qui répond
en parlant de l'histoire avec un petit h
celui de sa grand mère donc c'est aussi
ça c'est les relations
franco-algériennes aujourd'hui donc
c'est très important de voir aussi
comment ça se construit on a une
nouvelle génération qui veut aller de
l'avant qui veut parler des questions
mémorielles mais qui n'en fait pas une
fin en soi qui veut aussi construire des
passerelles et aller au delà merci
beaucoup meriem pour cet éclairage est
d'être passés nous voir merci meriem
retour en france on est à 26 jours 1 du
premier tour est pour l'heure est bien
le premier parti de france c'est
l'abstention oui selon un dernier
sondage ipsos qui date d'hier elle
atteindrait entre 32 et 36 % au premier
tour soit au moins dix points de plus
qu'en 2007 où elle s'était élevée à un
peu plus de 22% au premier tour
particulièrement forte chez les jeunes
qui peinent à s'intéresser aux autres
trains d'autant que cette année on en a
beaucoup parlé l'accompagné
particulièrement poussive reportage de
natacha besnik et maya anaïs iata guen
bonjour monsieur pour les élections
présidentielles vous comptez aller voter
tract après tracts cette militante
communiste ne lâche pas la faire elle
compte bien ramener vers les urnes le
plus d'abstentionnistes possible on va
aller chercher un as et est un véritable
fléau malheureusement c'est la
démocratie qui en pâtit a aubervilliers
l'une des villes les plus pauvres de
france aurélie doit convaincre des
électeurs complètement désabusé
promesses rendent et des bonnes paroles
et puis après si après ça tient là
l'abstention en france atteint des
niveaux alarmants les électeurs ne se
retrouvent plus dans l'offre politique
qui ne répond pas à leurs attentes
mais dans un pays où la défiance à
l'égard des institutions est
particulièrement élevé 1 par comparaison
à ses voisins notamment mais il n'ya pas
que des facteurs politiques il ya aussi
des facteurs sociodémographiques les
jeunes vont être beaucoup moins que les
personnes plus plus âgés les catégories
populaires votent aussi beaucoup moins
alors pour réenchanter la politique et
la rendre plus sexy des apps comme élise
s'inspire des sites de rencontres ces
étudiants analyse 25 propositions de
candidats instauré le droit de vote à 16
ans
trop jeunes beaucoup trop tôt ils
glissent leurs doigts vers la droite
s'ils sont d'accord vers la gauche s'ils
ne le sont pas l'application leur
indique alors le candidat dont il serait
le plus proche objectif c'est d'aider
n'importe quel jeune qui veut
s'intéresser à l'élection à mieux
comprendre les programmes des différents
candidats et l'aider à faire son choix
mais ensuite nous on est neutres à
partisans indépendant et quitte à
trouver avec quel candidat au match le
plus pourquoi ne pas le faire sur teen
d'heure le géant des sites de rencontres
n'autorise pas l'utilisation de son
service à des fins politiques mais il
s'est associé à une association anti
abstentions avec comme mot d'ordre si tu
dois est en bas de chez toi à leur vote
en bas de chez toi
et c'est fini on se retrouve demain avec
vous à chanaz démence 2022 l'heure du
choix chaque jour la chronique de la
campagne présidentielle ici en france on
se retrouve nous dans trois minutes pour
un nouveau journal